one of my lifelong goals is to find an
earth-sized planet in an earth-like
orbit about a sun-like star
one that has a thin atmosphere and that
has water oceans
one where we can point to a specific
star
and say that star has a planet like
earth
what i love to dream about is maybe
there's some life on that planet you
know looking back at our earth in our
star and saying the same thing
like how amazing would that be it would
be amazing
[Music]
now this idea that the stars have
planets of their own and that those
planets might have aliens living on them
has been around for centuries
at first it had some pretty harsh
critics
but by the 20th century it was
mainstream alien worlds showed up in
books and then movies and tv in this
galaxy there's a mathematical
probability of three million earth-type
planets
[Music]
but here's the thing even after all that
even when this episode of star trek the
next generation aired in 1987
scientists still hadn't confirmed the
existence of a single planet outside our
solar system
[Music]
for all we knew these so-called
exoplanets
could only be found in fiction
but the next generation of astronomers
armed with new telescopes and more
powerful computers set out to change
that this is sarah seeger she's a
professor of astrophysics at mit it's
the spirit of us being the first
explorers you know we get to see what's
out there for the very first time we get
to know if there are other planets like
ours here's a map of what they've found
so far
it's our night sky which is a sphere
projected onto this square map it's sort
of like one of the the maps of the world
it's like well obviously we're on a
globe but this is all stretched out yeah
it's all stretched out
the black dots are visible stars with
the north star polaris up here at the
top of the map and this band is the
densest part of our own milky way galaxy
the lines trace out constellations so we
can look for a familiar constellation
like the big dipper
up here and here's orion actually
[Music]
and these colorful dots mark the
position of stars with known exoplanets
the very first exoplanet around a
sun-like star wasn't discovered until
1995. it was called 51 pegasi b
and this was an incredible planet it was
astonishing it's about a jupiter mess
but the time that it takes to go around
its star remember jupiter takes 12 years
51 peg takes four days so it's a year is
four days long yeah i don't think you
could celebrate new year's
[Music]
but on 51 pegb you'd have other things
to worry about the planets in our solar
system that are about its size aren't
great places to live they're mainly just
hydrogen and helium you know there's no
surface it just gets hotter and hotter
and higher and higher pressure and
eventually we would melt and we would be
crushed plus it's really close to its
star much much closer than even mercury
is to our sun so it's likely as hot as
molten lava
[Music]
great what else we got after all this
dreaming for millennia
it turns out our very nearest star to
our sun
has a planet and that is proxima
centauri about an earth mass planet we
don't know the mass exactly and it's in
the habitable zone of that star
the goldilocks zone or the habitable
zone has the right temperature for
liquid water it's not too hot
not too cold
but just right for life the hotter the
star the further away you've got to be
basically
proxima centauri is a red dwarf much
cooler than our sun so you've got to be
really close to stay warm
when a planet is this close to its star
its rotation becomes locked meaning that
one side of the planet always faces
toward the star one always faces away
that's what happened to our moon that's
why we only see one side of it
if we could visit the planet the sun or
the star would be in the same place in
the sky at all times huh so so basically
yeah there'd be a line on the world
where it would always be sunset or
sunrise especially
what's going on with this giant blob
over here this blob is where nasa's
kepler space telescope stared at for
about four whole years
two engine start one zero and liftoff of
the delta ii rocket with kepler
the kepler space telescope found
thousands of exoplanets by focusing on
one patch of sky
here's all the discoveries made by other
telescopes and here's kepler's
contribution
so back here in the kepler field there's
a really interesting planet called
kepler-16b
it was the first one where one planet is
orbiting two stars sometimes science
fiction is right tatooine
but in this case it's a giant exoplanet
so once again probably not one where
we'd be walking around and talking to
obi-wan kenobi no no but still it is
supposedly in or near the habitable zone
of kepler-16 so people like to say if it
has a moon that moon actually could be
habitable
imagine the sky there lit by two suns
two shadows two sunsets and dominated by
a massive planet
okay let's look for pretty much the
favorite exoplanet system right now it's
called trappist one
it has seven planets around it and
they're all around about earth mass so
you were talking about
mercury before as sort of a reference
point for the distance of the star do
you know how
all these planets would be interior to
what would be mercury's orbit it's very
cute sort of planetary they're all lined
up in a plane you know if we were on one
of these planets we could see the other
planet in the sky would be like bigger
than our moon or something and probably
moving then like i mean you would look
up and see like a moon
shooting across your scene for amateur
astronauts
scientists think that planets enf fall
into that sweet sweet goldilocks zone
but even if that's off some of these
planets must be the right temperature
for life
the james webb space telescope which
launched on christmas morning 2021 it
has targeted every planet in the
trappist system so we'll be learning a
lot more about it and what's going to be
different about that versus what we've
seen before the james webb will be much
more powerful it has a bigger collecting
area
and it'll be orbiting very far from
earth where the environment is just
quieter and darker plus the telescope
can see infrared light which will make
it easier to study exoplanet atmospheres
this is where the science seems to be
headed fewer surveys of broad swaths of
sky
more targeted investigations of nearby
stars and the atmospheres of planets
we've already found to see if any of our
neighbors might support life
you know there's sort of a habitable
zone for marshmallows too actually there
really is and it's down here right
that's right yeah
okay here we go
oh
yeah
so we found like four thousand
yes thousands thousands of planets
thousands of planets what has been most
exciting to you it's everything i mean
it's the sheer surprise like we'll find
planets we had no idea existed in our
nice familiar system we've got a handful
of petite rocky planets and a handful of
massive fluffy giants and nothing in
between
but out in the rest of the galaxy the
most common planets we've found are big
dense rocks nicknamed super earths and
big less dense sub-neptunes
to me what's the most mysterious is our
solar system is not incredibly common
the surveys have been going on for long
enough that they should have seen lots
and lots of jupiters but they
maybe only found one or two that
resemble ours
and still no sign of a true earth twin
do you think that that's out there it's
definitely out there somewhere
the question is is one around a near
enough star
that the telescopes we're trying to
build can actually find
even if we do find that though
it won't be for a long time that we ever
are able to visit or communicate and
maybe never
so what's the point people always ask me
why are we doing this you know why are
we
searching for other planets why do we
want to find another earth
it's human nature to explore
we want to know what's out there we've
surveyed all the land on earth most of
the oceans
and what's out there now is outer space
we want to try to understand why are we
here how did our earth come to be
and finding other worlds like our own is
a step in that direction
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you